[Music]
what's Heaven it's a peaceful place in
the sky
are you going to heaven
no
why not
you gotta be a good person to go to
heaven
10 years ago today the artificial
intelligence created to protect us
detonated a nuclear warhead in Los
Angeles
yeah
as long as AI is a threat
we will never stop hunting mountains no
this is a fight for our very existence
whatever's in there they're sure worried
about someone getting in
yeah we're good now
we're the same we can't go to heaven
cause you're not good
[Music]
and I'm not a person
did you locate the weapon yeah it's a
key
belt
away
this close to winning a war
execute her or we go extinct
[Applause]
they're coming to get me
foreign
[Music]